The ability to choose.
In fact, so many questions about why things happen
are answered with just simply humanity's ability
to make a choice.
And choices really are what governs so much of our lives
from the easiest decisions to some of the hardest
to choices that take forever to make
and ones that we make in an instant.
And it's choices that are so powerful
and they're a privilege and they're a responsibility
and it's something that God has given us.
And this is one of those, again,
one of those pointers to who God is
and the fact that he exists.
But here's the key question.
How do students' choices,
how do all of our choices actually reflect God?
How do the things that we choose,
whether it be right, whether it be wrong, good, bad,
ugly, whatever it is,
how do those choices reflect God?
Some of our choices obviously do.
A lot of our choices obviously don't.
But when we talk about our ability to choose
and the fact that God gave it to us,
there's some things we really have to make sure
we nail down with our students.
So we're challenging students with two things.
Number one, that our free will points us to him.
The fact that we have free will
is a pointer to who he is.
It helps us understand that because we have the ability
to choose that God is out there somewhere.
But number two, our free will should reflect him
and how we behave as Christians
ought to be a reflection of who he is.
So as you go about your unit this week,
I want you to keep something in mind.
I want you to take,
last week we took a temperature of our students
to figure out where the students are.
This week I want you to take temperature of your community.
Now we talked at the very beginning
about the importance of establishing a community,
a strong community, a community that is open,
one that loves, one that's close,
one that students feel safe in.
We talked about that kind of being an overarching goal
of being able to communicate truth and love
is to have a community where students feel safe
to ask questions and so forth.
So how is that community doing?
How is it working?
Are there adjustments that you need to make?
It's so easy, especially as a leader of large groups
to figure out, okay, how are all these groups working?
Is there other issues?
Are there not?
Does everybody feel that they belong?
Even if you only do a small group yourself,
it's really easy to get caught up and forget
about maybe one particular student
that has a ton of really great things to say.
But for some reason,
doesn't feel like they can say those things.
So it's good to take a step back,
take a look at our communities
and see are we hitting the mark, but where we wanna be.
So a couple of things I want you to think about.
Are leaders providing the right atmosphere?
Are they crafting that sort of atmosphere of discussion?
One that questions our welcome,
one of grace and love, but with truth
and not letting one student dominate,
inviting all students to participate.
All of those pieces of the puzzle
is the right kind of atmosphere being fostered.
Number two, are students being loved?
And are they being challenged?
So often we kind of confuse the two
and we think that for loving students
and we're just kind of letting them think
what they wanna think and we're,
in my experience, the most challenged students that I had
in terms of how much I challenged them
were the ones that felt most loved
at the end of a year.
Those are the ones that felt like they were valued.
Go to any school, in any classroom,
where in the middle of things, students are frustrated,
they're under pressure, and they think a teacher
or somebody is really too hard on them
and they complain about it.
If you notice, go back to those schools
and ask those teachers how many graduates
come back to see them.
And the number's probably pretty high.
The more, sort of works this way,
the more challenging you are with the student,
the greater respect you gain
and the greater love that you are showing them.
It just works that way.
So make sure that you love them
but make sure that you also challenge them.
Number three, do they feel safe to be honest?
I mean, if we're loving them properly,
then that's probably gonna be the case
that they do feel safe.
But there are some things that we want students
to be honest but sometimes their honesty
causes us to have to react in a way
that they don't want us to react.
But do they feel safe?
Do they feel like they can be honest with us
and then we're gonna react appropriately?
Number four, are your small groups serving one another?
Are you guys in your small groups caring for one another?
Have you created a community where you love each other
or the students are loving on each other?
It isn't just a place where you kind of come together,
say a few things and then off you go
into something else and off to your real friends
or whatever the case is.
Are your small groups becoming a tight knit community
of people who care and love for one another?
And I would encourage you as a next step for that
is to take those and get those students out
into the community whether it be the wider community
or even just the church community
and find places for them to serve together
and do things together to help build
and foster that kind of community.
All right, so you've almost made it
to the halfway point.
Congratulations, keep it up.
You guys are doing a great job, I am sure.
And remember, some of your students might be starting
to feel some of the stress of school
because you're probably getting around midterms
and finals and tests and quizzes
and those kinds of things.
So now would be a really good time
and this is a really good lesson
to do some fun things, to have some fun
with students on making choices,
whether it be through games,
whether it be through examples, something silly,
where you could have a whole bunch of fun
having students make choices
but at the same time,
teach them the power of those choices.